desde que las personas se prestan dinero
mutuamente ha existido un problema
fundamental
qué sucede cuando alguien no puede pagar
sus deudas
y por el momento no pensemos en qué es
lo que sucede en nuestra sociedad
moderna veamos qué es lo que pasaba en
la antigüedad y hay algunas palabras que
vamos a usar frecuentemente en el
contexto del préstamo monetario en un
lado de la transacción tenemos al deudor
la persona que tomó prestado el dinero
toma prestado
el dinero
y ya que toma prestado dinero ahora esta
persona debe dinero del otro lado de la
transacción tenemos al acreedor acreedor
la entidad o persona que proporciona el
dinero al deudor o que se lo presta el
acreedor da el dinero
o presta el dinero
es el dueño del dinero básicamente así
que tenemos nuestros términos
principales pero regresemos a nuestro
tema principal qué sucede cuando el
deudor no puede pagarle al acreedor el
dinero prestado si vemos la historia
humana veremos que se han tenido
diferentes soluciones a este problema si
vemos en la antigua grecia
antigua grecia
tenían una solución muy sencilla si el
deudor no podía pagar su deuda al
acreedor se volvía un esclavo de deuda
esclavo
o más que esclavo de deuda esclavo por
deuda
así que si el acreedor necesitaba que le
arreglara en su jardín o que le
limpiaran su casa de manera regular el
deudor y probablemente también la
familia del deudor tenían que hacer lo
que le dijera el acreedor hasta que
pagaran su deuda mediante el trabajo
y así es como en la antigua grecia se
trataba este problema y bueno puede
parecernos sorprendente a nosotros
actualmente pero esa era la solución que
se daba en ese entonces si tomabas
prestado dinero y no lo podías pagar
esto es lo que tenías que hacer si nos
adelantamos un poquito en la historia a
épocas medievales lo que ocurría y de
hecho es algo que le pasó el papá de
charles dickens que se vio atrapado en
este tipo de circunstancia a mediados
del siglo 19 en eeuu y en europa lo que
ocurría es que existían la prisión de
los deudores
prisión
deudores
y esto a mí me parece que es todavía
peor que el ser esclavo por deuda ya que
en la prisión de deudores le metían a la
cárcel o encarcelaban al deudor
encarcelan al deudor
por eso se llama prisión de deudores
y el deudor no podía salir libre a menos
que su familia pagara toda la deuda
entonces el deudor era encarcelado hasta
que la familia o amigos o amigos si es
que tenía buenos amigos pagaban la deuda
y pagarán la deuda
y démonos cuenta porque esto es
especialmente horroroso ya que al menos
aquí uno tenía la oportunidad de pagar
la deuda trabajando en cambio aquí si
por ejemplo yo tengo una deuda y mi hijo
de diez meses la única familia que tengo
pues no va a poder pagar mi deuda así
que yo me voy a quedar en prisión o
quizá no le caigo bien a mi familia oa
lo mejor no tengo familia y es terrible
que si por ejemplo le debo a alguien el
equivalente a mil pesos y no lo puedo
pagar me quede toda la vida en prisión
porque no tengo nadie que me ayude a
pagarlo así que como se pueden imaginar
esta prisión de deudores era bastante
terrible y de hecho el padre de charles
dickens estuvo en esta prisión de
deudores y esto les puede indicar el por
qué él escribía este tipo de libros pero
bueno este es el pasado ahora estamos en
una sociedad civilizada y pareciera que
tenemos mejores maneras de tratar de
solucionar estas situaciones y este es
el tema de este vídeo ahora lo que
tenemos es un término llamado bancarrota
y las primeras versiones de la
bancarrota no eran muy diferentes de la
prisión de deudores
siempre buscaban proteger al acreedor en
lugar de proteger al deudor pero ahora
tenemos leyes de bancarrota que nos
ayudan a evitar estas soluciones locas
así que hablemos un poco más sobre la
bancarrota
bancarrota y nos vamos a enfocar en la
bancarrota cómo está legislada en eeuu
enfocada en estados unidos- y nos vamos
a enfocar en la bancarrota personal
aunque mucho de lo que voy a hablar en
varios niveles se parece a lo que sucede
cuando las empresas tienen que ponerse
en bancarrota digamos que estoy saturada
de deudas le debo a las tarjetas de
crédito miles de dólares tengo una
hipoteca en mi casa tengo un préstamo
para pagar mi auto y qué puedo hacer
para solucionar esto hay un par de
opciones que proporcionan en eeuu una es
el capítulo 7 y podría parecer muy
complicado ya que hay diferentes
capítulos en el código de la bancarrota
así que aquí tenemos el capítulo 7
y se llama bancarrota directa
y bueno aunque no es un procedimiento
sencillo lo que sucede básicamente es
que uno va a declararse en bancarrota ya
que no se pueden pagar las deudas y lo
que van a hacer estas personas es tomar
todos mis bienes y los van a dividir
entre mis acreedores y una vez que
termine todo este procedimiento yo no
tendré deuda alguna claro que tampoco
tendré ningún bien verdad quizás a lo
mejor me dejen algo básico para vivir a
lo mejor un traje para poder ir a pedir
empleo o mis sartenes o una televisión
si acaso pero por ejemplo si yo tuviera
una cuenta bancaria aunque probablemente
no lo tengo ya que estoy toda endeudada
pero si yo tuviera una cuenta bancaria
al declararla en bancarrota directa todo
lo que tenga en esa cuenta bancaria va a
salir y va a ser usado para pagar mi
deuda a los acreedores así que después
de que me quitan todos mis bienes al
final del día no tendré yo deudas con
nadie así que es una manera de romper el
círculo vicioso de la
y muchos se preguntarán bueno pues por
qué no hacer esto siempre para salir de
deudas bueno hay ciertas reglas que se
tienen que aplicar para poder acceder a
ese tipo de bancarrota y otra cosa que
sucede es que esto permanece en su
historial crediticio durante diez años
en historial
y crediticio
así que uno tiene que pensar con cuidado
si es que se va a ir por esta opción ya
que si yo tengo oportunidad de pagar mi
deuda durante los próximos diez años
pues es mejor no declararme bancarrota
esforzarme por pagar esta deuda antes de
estos diez años y evitarme tener esta
cosa espantosa en mi historial
crediticio pero si esa es una situación
que verdaderamente yo ya no puedo
manejar pues ésta sería una muy buena
opción hay que recordar que esto no
puede aplicarse a cualquier
circunstancia así yo por ejemplo tengo
una deuda estudiantil de 30 mil dólares
y que sé que no voy a poder pagar en
diez años pues voy a declararme en
bancarrota pero los préstamos
estudiantiles no son susceptibles para
que uno se declare en bancarrota y hay
bastantes tipos de deudas o de préstamos
que no son aplicables para este capítulo
7 en el que uno no puede declararse en
bancarrota
algunos son como ya había mencionado los
préstamos estudiantiles impuestos
manutención de los hijos entre otros
así que antes de decidirse por alguno de
los capítulos que voy a mencionar aquí
siempre procuren consultar con un
experto en leyes esto es simplemente es
una revisión general de estos conceptos
así que resumiendo la bancarrota directa
del capítulo 7 es cuando yo no tengo la
manera de pagar mi deuda me quitan todos
mis bienes para pagar las deudas y tengo
un nuevo comienzo y el siguiente
capítulo es uno que ustedes escucharán
más seguido con respecto a la bancarrota
personal y este es el capítulo 13
capítulo 13
y esto se refiere a la reorganización
organización la idea aquí es que yo
tengo un empleo tengo un salario pero
tengo demasiadas deudas y esto es quizás
no por irresponsabilidad mía a lo mejor
tuviera una situación médica una
operación o una enfermedad severa que me
dejó endeudada o gastos inesperados que
me dejaron sin nada así que aquí la
situación es decir bueno señores
acreedores yo de verdad quiero pagarles
la deuda pero no tengo con qué hacerlo
al menos en este momento me es imposible
hacer si me obligan a hacerlo voy a
terminar en el capítulo 7 declarando
bancarrota directa así que tanto por mi
bien y el de ustedes tanto para mí como
deudor como para ustedes como acreedores
porque no hacemos un plan realista en el
que yo pueda pagarles dentro de los
próximos tres o cinco años por ejemplo
que ustedes como acreedores me digan que
en lugar de verles 50 mil dólares les
deba 40 mil o que la tasa de interés de
mi tarjeta de crédito
el 20 por ciento anual pues que sea el
10 por ciento así que aquí hay un poco
de negociación y encontrar así un plan
de pagos en el que yo les pagaré mi
deuda dentro de tres o cinco años
nuevamente ustedes me pueden decir oye
pues esto está muy bien me pueden
reducir mi deuda o reducir la tasa de
interés ir con mis acreedores aparentar
ser un individuo responsable y apelar
ante ellos para que me reduzcan la deuda
y esto me convendrá mucho más que si no
lo hago pero nuevamente aquí hay una
penalización por hacer esto y también
aparece en el historial crediticio así
que por ejemplo si yo acuerdo que les
voy a pagar esta deuda a mis proveedores
en tres años el estatus de bancarrota va
a aparecer en mi historial crediticio
durante los siguientes siete años
en historial crediticio
así que desde el momento en el que
ustedes se declaran en ese tipo de
bancarrota hasta que pasan todos estos
años en donde aparece el estatus en el
historial crediticio van a haber pasado
diez años justo como en el capítulo 7
así que en cualquiera de estas dos
situaciones esto no es algo para hacer a
la ligera no son una salida fácil al
problema de mi deuda son cosas bastante
serias que me van a impactar durante
varios años mi historial crediticio sin
embargo son cosas útiles de saber en el
caso que esperemos que no se den pero
que tengamos que llegar a esos extremos
de que tenemos muchas deudas no podemos
pagar es bueno saber que al menos
existen un par de salidas a este
problema ya que a pesar de todo quizás
dentro de unos siete o diez años
dependiendo de la solución que escojamos
voy a poder comenzar de nuevo sin
problemas y para que se den una idea de
que tan frecuentemente se usan estas
soluciones yo busqué en internet
la cantidad de personas que caen en
estos capítulos en eeuu sobre todo
porque se encuentran en un periodo de
recesión así que las declaraciones de
bancarrota son muy frecuentes entonces
por ejemplo aquí está el capítulo 7
capítulo 7 y aquí va a estar el capítulo
13 capítulo 3 y hay varios capítulos
intermedios existe un capítulo 12 que es
básicamente el capítulo 13 pero para
granjeros y pescadores que se les
proporciona un poco más de beneficios de
lo que él tiene las demás personas ya
que se interesa promover a las personas
que producen la comida y también está el
capítulo 11 que básicamente es
reorganización pero de negocios aunque
pueden aplicar a ciertos individuos que
tienen bastante influencia y que sus
bienes están más relacionados o parecen
más como los de un negocio así que en
este caso el capítulo 11 es más
apropiado que el capítulo 13 ellos son
los otros dos capítulos que hay pero
desde el punto de la bancarrota personal
el capítulo 7 y el capítulo 13
los que aplican así que veamos los
números de declaraciones de bancarrota
en cada uno de estos capítulos que se
han dado en eeuu y que han estado
aumentando desde entonces desde el 2007
2008 y 2009 pues para que vean que si
ustedes caen en algunas de estas
situaciones pues vean que no están solos
del capítulo 7 en el año 2007 en eeuu se
dierón 413 mil casos de declaración de
bancarrota directa en el 2008 hubieron
560 mil casos más del 25% con respecto
al año anterior y en el año 2009 819 mil
casos se registraron básicamente el
doble de lo que había en el 2007 en el
caso del capítulo 13 en el 2007 hubieron
277 mil casos registrados
aproximadamente por cuatro registros del
capítulo 7 había tres registros del
capítulo 13 en el año 2008 hubieron 330
4000 casos y en el 2009 hubieron 370 mil
casos y como pueden ver aunque ambos
están aumentando el que está aumentando
más es el capítulo 7 ya que ustedes se
pueden imaginar en las situaciones en
las que las personas no tienen trabajo
el capítulo 13 no puede aplicar no les
queda más que entrar en el capítulo 7
espero que hayan encontrado esta
información útil y conozcan un poco más
sobre la bancarrota